oh you can see you can see the
reflection of what I see but kind of
distorted yes I'm waiting for a game top
2500 so over 4000 players playing I
guess I'm tied for last place
there we go it's a whale okay Wow
looks decent oh I'm playing him you play
a point buzzer king i guess i'll bezerk
back let's play play for play something
mildly aggressive another sub fig guys
something something whoa it's it's bits
yeah that's that's probably more than
not but there's no such thing as more
than thanks for the bits trying to
remember my my preparation I'm playing
inst an Italian thanks so much with yeah
those are the the Danny wizard the
testing that's ten thousand testing bits
so my intention is to a five six I'm
gonna play d4 if Bishop c5 maybe I'll
play some gambit oh so a point has other
readings this is typical like with
classical chests not everyone gets a
classical reading until they play a
tournament like this I miss I miss my
opportunity for the Jerome but I'm gonna
play a line that it's one of those the
first openings I learned back when I was
like eight or nine years old it's called
the molar attack it's essentially a
gambit I think it can also be called the
molar gambit but it's a position after
Knight takes e4 yeah
so I gamba the pawn but box King is
still in the center
a lot of tricks and traps in the slide
real Jack or welcome back
slumming for nine months nine months
wait what's them oh yeah I was about to
take the the main line is defied though
okay we'll see if my opponent knows
theory I forgot who coined this but
someone was saying that I'm nine months
sub is at which baby Wow opponent knows
theory I'm slightly scared but I guess
this is like a some wioa opponent it's
struggling with internet connection this
is a kind of well-known line it's the
type of line ok counseling's not the
main move me move his 97 Lin Joey
thanks for the bits hi hi so the main
line was 97 takes and then d6 21 to draw
I'm thinking I should take and then 97
then I can play d6 and try and
capitalize on the fact that well first
Bach has to move the night and then g6
is coming pretty much no matter what
okay Knight a5 attacks of bishop it'll
just retreat want to leave the night off
center someday I'm dreaming of trapping
the Knights I'm not quite possible yet
so hype I mark 89 thanks for every sub
for two months so there's a few ideas
I'm considering here there's there's
rook b1 to prepare before there's a line
rook p1 Bishop e7 be for traps and
knights and then the line takes takes
takes takes should be better for white
Nikola thanks for the bits
[ __ ] that's Brooke peatones the type of
move I probably can just play quickly
now there's some idea for black to play
Knight b7 but then the knight kind of
interferes with the bishop okay
f PG McLovin that's enough Rosen's one
more rosin span and there might be have
to might be have to what was I going to
say
Oh Twinkle Twinkle thanks for the thanks
for the sub anyway okay I'm trying to
focus this is supposed to be slow
instructive classical chest even though
this is kind of rapid because we beserk
yeah Knight b7 maybe sevens actually a
decent move because the lights gonna
land here and then the bishops gonna
come to to b7 so I mean ideally I'd like
to attack move like rook g4 could be
possible allows d6 there's also be four
right away like B for preventing Knight
c5 if 96 then I'll play this and there's
no pawn d6 in the meantime yeah I'm
gonna have a lot of pieces aimed at the
King side yeah my bones playing well for
the whatever I guess they're not rapping
right in either okay can't complain
about the position even though I'm down
the pawn lots of activity also passed
pawn quadruple nine subbing for 25
months while one of the longest subs of
this channel thanks so much
so there's about four
I think the goal the goal is just to
keep improving also Rob brush with a
prime sub sattvic P solving for half a
year and Lord snaps also subbing with
primer each five while so age five I
think my rook can sit comfortably on g3
the G file is a closed file but I kind
of turned it into a usable file for the
rook a 94 good move all right let's take
hmm also harsh gifting subs thanks so
much harsh a little bit flustering
there's a lot on calculating takes takes
and then Bishop g5 and takes takes I hit
the rock I also hit the pawn kind of
like that
the problem with Bishop g5 though I
don't know there's a clear threat
maybe the thread is 92 at the rook and
hit the pawn wow so many new subs h4
played so quickly well this [ __ ] for
work up one's playing very strongly
which were probably works
I could take actually I could take and
then row gauge 335 probably take some
rough t5 I'm getting outplayed though I
would give shoutouts to the sub but are
the new subs
let's play with g5
I'll give shoutouts after this game I
have to focus
I'm still down the pawn box kind of
neutralized I have a sneaky threat
though whoa it's PAP a shout-out to Pepe
someone gives Pepe a shout-out in the
chat
to rage to the power are whoa it's happy
with a sub - thanks so much Pepe also
becoming a twitch baby with a nine month
streak
oh it's Johanna - shout-out to Joanna
opponent keeps offering me a draw the
thing so there's a there is an important
piece of advice when the point offers
you a draw on their turn the best
approach is to not say or do anything it
was just to wait until they make a move
because I'm the offer is still valid
after they make a move I'm not accepting
it yeah so my plan was to play Queen C
to attack the rook and attack the pawn I
think that's approach I mean Bishop f5
could be scary but what else to do
all those rook is not feeling
comfortable there's a few tricks maybe
let's try this
we're hitting this in this thing's past
falling using the mod power the shoutout
power I'm Bishop a5 played so the idea
was to just do this I'm realizing this
probably loses but what else to do wait
a minute
if I take and then it doesn't work
I'm gonna fight yeah I work out for a
good move so I have to take the bishop
otherwise blocks going to take and then
win this if I move my rook
it's a minimal compensation Casey Casey
AG thanks for subbing it's time for T to
say calm even in difficult situations
situations becoming more difficult
I'm in the smooth
the very least like give black a choice
try and create some possibility of black
blundering okay that didn't really
accomplish much unless so I can play
rook e8 a rookie there's Queenie one Wow
I think I'm just dead and I'm I don't
really have a square for my knight
oh I guess rookie a queen do you want to
have rookie one let's try this it's not
gonna end well
let's blitz rating hundred games Wow
look out three
yeah Rock f3 is probably most precise
haven't had one of these in a while
black taking time here yeah what to do
there's a few reasons to play on of
course the ultimate hope is perpetual
lock still taking time display only
having one legal move
I'm just looking for ways to actually
I'll explain after the game now this
sort of situation don't necessarily want
to resign
it's just going on YouTube I don't know
how I feel about like uploading videos
like this okay three okay we'll see a
flat can check made me in the most
efficient way possible as it force means
you don't know if it's forced meet
control efore mmm
all it takes is one mouse lip quite
nicely
yeah that was unfortunate I mean the
sort of game like Rick definitely
requires some analysis is castling a
mainline Oh casting is very much a
secondary move Wow
yeah night 97 is like the the main line
that almost all the strong players play
but I don't know I don't know if I could
have improved given that I feel like
most of box moves where they're pretty
flawless also thanks for subbing SIF man
sift the caveman ass if man is SIF
caveman without the cave appreciate the
Sun so it was H 5 yeah so H 5 it's like
a very unnatural move but engines top
choice and then also was b6 all right
yeah also like Knight a5 the concept of
95 b6 is also very unnatural the
computer stuff choice and this is
easiest people can't see yeah
well that's unfortunate starts I usually
enjoy playing like real people but yeah
what to do
we chess is usually pretty good at
responding to these sort of things they
already respond
hey I got my reading refund
good job Lee Ches I didn't you have to
go reports can I show this hmm I would
show like a rating refund message but I
want to show off my DMS so I just you my
dad okay well that was a weird start man
I don't know do I want to play more slow
chess that doesn't happen like so often
Oh jaybird 1977 thanks for subbing put
this on youtube
playing an obvious computer cheater
there's been a lot of chess brought
contents and chess bras been
encountering a lot of computer cheaters
and it is interesting content just watch
watch the engine play good chess yeah I
got refunded 41 classical points
let's go this was interesting it was an
interesting opening moment yeah I really
don't want to spend too much more time
like talking about this but I do want to
maybe show show a lesson from the
opening it's one of the very first
opening traps I learned and it's in the
molar attack after takes castles at
least from a human standpoint it looks
very natural to take with Knight takes
and then hit the rook in the hand and
this is one of the main traps black and
falling - I think objectively the best
move here is Bishop e3 but the line that
I was taught growing up actually had
some success playing this and in turn in
play is was it Queen b3 hitting the
bishop hitting the pawn black takes the
rook and then Bishop takes f7 King f8
actually starting with Bishop f7
White's white keeps throwing punches
until the positions winning so Bishop g5
almost trapping the queen forcing 97 and
then very powerful move 95 a double idea
of Queen here also idea of vision of g6
and Queen f7 mates and we check this on
me chess there's a d4 yeah so the line
goes like this fish of g6 and I think
White's just completely winning so it's
a cool kind of choppy line mmm